uh mandy do you remember when we went to
alaska on that trip where we were
swimming with the killer whales and uh
and and we
we made this was this was one i couldn't
believe we got this on tv we took a uh a
female
salmon a big salmon fish and by by
running the finger down like the middle
of the bottom of the salmon they were
able to push all of the salmon eggs
out of the salmon and into my mouth so
they remember they filled my they filled
my mouth with uh just
jamming their finger down and all the
eggs fly into my mouth and then they
grab a male salmon and they do the same
thing with the male salmon and they run
their fingers down and and it was just
salmon [ __ ] they they there was so
much semen came out of this salmon and
just sprayed my whole face and filled my
mouth with with fish
these salmon had also been dead out of
the water after they died
longer washed up on the bank they
weren't they weren't they were like half
rotten you know what i mean they stunk
they were already
even if it was cooked that sand was
cooked i wouldn't eat it no way no way
would i eat one of those salmons i found
on the bank of that river laying out
there like that
there yeah they were
i remember everybody was cracking
cracking up man but he goes i'm gonna
save and incubate these salmon eggs
back in the water yeah jesus did you
spit or swallow steve
yeah good question i'm reasonably sure
that i was a spitter that day
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude